this course in a lot of ways sort of
trying to do something new that I
haven't seen among the university before
where you know they're trying out a new
project that has a real application but
I think that that's what makes it
equally exciting and worth coming to and
given like a really unique
responsibility where you're creating
something new which i think is a great
opportunity especially as an undergrad
we have a group of 40 students and the
first challenge that they're asked to
solve is how do we work together how do
we really kind of start to integrate all
these diverse voices and perspectives to
come together towards something quite
cohesive and exciting and vibrant the
course that I'm teaching right now is
responsible mobile environments and
that's paired with building an
atmosphere course in the school of
architecture by Christina and we're
looking at Martian biomes for sustaining
plants in remote habitats I chose to
develop this course during my fellowship
to think about how we design for outer
space and one of the things that was
most interesting about that was the
ability to teach an interdisciplinary
class with students actually studying
from different majors was fantastic I'm
very interested in outerspace I'm
interested in building and I'm excited
about our future in terms of exploring
other planets and new frontiers and why
not start in school I think the most
interesting jobs I've karen's class is
that everyone has a different area of
knowledge I was really drawn to you know
having the opportunity through the idea
program sort of work with people that
were outside of my discipline and find
new ways to apply my discipline I'm
figuring out like you know lots of
problems which I didn't know it really
existed because I've never built
something before actually making a final
physical product is a great thing I'm
taking away from the course it's been a
very well consulted course by
professionals so it's been really
helpful we've had some really great
involvement from people outside the
class a lot of support from the NASA
community we've talked to people who are
developing inflatables we've had
somebody from the Jet Propulsion labs in
here there's a lot of interest from NASA
to improve the education and to really
be involved we've also talked to people
who are developing commercial plant
growth systems we've had people give
remote lectures from Europe about
closed-loop ecosystems that are being
developed by the European Space Agency
so we had this great opportunity to
really interact with the outside world
and we're hoping to continue to do that
make the experience not only for the
students
and for faculty but also for a wider
audience
you